assistant of the reject Nation before I go
into anything else I wanted to say that real
reix has a new boys inspired t-shirt just
finished it it's coming in the mail for
AMW we wearing it for episode 7 but I'm going
to show you guys what it looks like right now
you should get it you should get it here it is
ah get it America's ass it's a play on that is
America's ass you get it yeah you get it smart
cook I love that shirt I love it can't wait to
be wearing for the last couple episodes J V
that shirt is available at reation shop.com
John how are you I am germinating voraciously
in anticipation oh you're doing it oh Coy you
just got back from nycc hosting panels how you
doing how's your voice absent and I have no gen
V puns because my brain isn't working and that
was intimidating John all righty well ladies
and gentlemen you know what to do leave a like
on this video subscribe click the notification
Bell cuz we're going to be covering jmv episode
78 thank you all have been watching with us and
thank you to all have been joining our patreon
page where over there we offer the full length
Reaction watch along that's where you sync up with
your own copy of gen V but we also cover several
shows over there exclusively with the highlights
and watch Longs included let's get into reaction
people remember everything I made you forget who
whoa oh so this episode's going to start off with
people forgetting and remembering stuff it's start
off with remembering in the EP and forgetting
there's always a mirror thing that happen it's a
good point go get Sam now she knows how much she
loves him also you're no can't use that word
on Twitter learn that you were in my head why
the girls get a done poster okay doing the right
thing oh oh is she going to have the aneurism yeah
she's using too much power damn look at this she
made lank blue ass set damn went from a super red
set that to a super blue set it's calmer in here
it's homeless you know getting into God you was
the best day of my life and it's no different than
the [__] hole I grew up in we haven't found out
who's like her benefactor sponsor or what's the
word right you're right we haven't some someone is
vouching she was over just like the rest of us no
she was a part of it Marie I think we should talk
to her you're just mad because you're sleeping
with her this some hella manipulation layers
he's going through help I need some help in here I
know it's true Andre can't touch his trust his dad
trust pulse is slowing can you spe it up
I don't know I I am what if it kills her
just do something be a hero do some blood
stuff be a hero make the blood go out of
her eyes that is such a different skill
than explode out blood yeah oh I like
the stranger things like music she's
breathing she's breathing you do care
who is this that's we haven't met this person
right was I'm assuming just a guinea pig how
long has she been like this since I injected
the virus two days ago the control is starting
to work the virus only affects soups this is the
payoff for all the work I've done of Sam a way to
compassionately control s God loves man kill stuff
so dangerous for of V we will be ready to submit
today not until we're ready we are ready results
are exactly what they'd be looking for it's the
very reason the woods exist that was two days ago
champ Dr cardos it but we mustn't get premature
what do you mean prematures when something
happens early she might die in the next like 5
minutes let's see how sick we can make her o oh my
let's develop a biochemical weapon yeah I an even
greater one the on the at make the hydrogen bomb
instead of the atom bomb it is too round on the
top it needs to be pointy has she ever pushed this
much before who cares is what she gets from my her
friends she can turn invisible what Marvel's
crossover what whoa she has so many Powers is this
her doing or someone taking her she
telekinetic what is happening oh this
guy oh [__] Happ Me Maybe Kate's more powerful
than we thought maybe she's in your heads yeah
maybe she's like a phoenix situation going
cuz there's like the house is gone they're
not they're not really there's an impact here
maybe she's got telekinesis and telepathy Caleb
who is that come back please oh we're in her
mind oh this her brother yeah great call Snap
mommy Kate wait just wait there and she said her
mom hasn't touched touched her ever since this
is a memory like Rogue I don't feel safe with
her we're in Kate's head it was an accident why
did Caleb listen to me he never does oh hey do
you like dogs you got a canine unit over here
to let your pet one all right just come with me
great visuals memories R yeah give me a little
distance would you peeling the bark back to
the truth beneath what are you Soldier Boy
soldja boy what are you doing in here I'm Gate's
imaginary friend when she was a kid oh no way
boyfriend really how cool how to off diddle that
Skittle flick the bean how to find that man in the
canoe Soldier Boy pillow she'd raw that pillow
till she saw God oh my God Jen Ackles having
the best time I know you hey you Kate's new boy
boy she really loves you I know you like hair
shorter boys they come and go but she always
comes back to a little pillow talk this is as
good as the cap Cameo at the end of homecoming
turns out you were radicalized by the Russians
you I'm no Godless kamie I'm red blooded but not
Kami red red white and blue red I fart the star
spangle Banner knock knock who's there go your
face okay it's like less Grossman Kate want you
in here for some reason you better figure it
out quick though before you get stuck in here
love that you can play it as an 11 because
it's literally a figment of Her Imagination
of him yeah see that that wasn't lightning as a
burst blood vessel Kate's head is unraveling in
real time she becomes a vegetable so do you oh
my god see you die in here real life deception
and the single most important thing I can tell
you of course no of oh jeez I love that Cameo
so much oh this could be a really trippy episode
that was such a clever way to have a came in in
this cannon without messing with the boy's
Cannon you came back oh good Heroes always
come back right you remember they're both so
broken in into each other the best kind of love
Yeah a you to should we yeah you mean like yeah
yes just I've uh he's never done it right why
would he I've never yeah Theory confirmed
and and he's competent but I want to with
you they're so sweet and weird knowing her luck
she's going to get pregnant right away yeah and
die I like how yellow's used positively in
this scene usually yellow is like unnerving
but he's unnerving so it's like a nice
yellow it's like an 80s love making scene
yeah it's like sweet in a way he's going
to invent the atomic bomb thinking about
this scene for years to come please don't do
something horrible I'm very worried for the
show yeah every thing is a nightmare I was
so worried are you okay Sam just roll with
it man just stay in stay in the zone
this episode brought you by the letter
f o damn volume Etc in an equation whoa
oh Jesus wow keep your distance and don't
let her touch you who is this oh I see hey
recruitment when it All Began I'm not afraid
of you Kate got soldier boy in the background
there smart with all the Queen B stuff too how
long have they kept you here 9 years I can't
imagine how hard that must be for you to to
Bear you don't have to wear the gloves if
you don't want to I trust you she so good
at manipulating you know her social skills
are actually surprisingly really good for
someone who's been this caged yeah eye contact
presence your mother is afraid because you are
exceptionally powerful what you need is help
understanding your power so smart to become
the surrogate mom oh yeah that's a really good
point she has no one yeah so clever sometimes
the thoughts are so loud I feel like I'm going
crazy make the voices stop come to Professor
shet saviors don't take the blue pill if
you take these every day the voices won't
bother you anymore I would love one of those
historically they work out well do you like a
hug poor woman oh look at that shot that's
clever whoa whoa I haven't been to class in
years Welcome Back Kid this this a long for the
rer yeah he's just trapped with them Golden Boy
Golden Boy tell hey sleeping with your girl
you just died but like you know it's cool
right I'm Bobby Bobby Drake here's an ice flower
welcome to mut could I cheat off of you you're
going to ride my coattails all the way to
the top they're so at reincorporating him
into the show we we should we should leave
I can't be here where are you going to go I
miss you man oh oh boy but it's her mind doing
this projection of him that's it's not really
him she thinks I mean she thinks he'd say do
I miss you too man so much but not so much
that I'm you know not sleeping with your
girlfriend you thought I didn't know no
what Andre what's he talking about oh damn it
was already happening yeah I was going to say
as hasn't going on that's why it happened
so quick and naturally oh oh they're all
going to see it great well let us see it yeah
come on it's better than the fragle the other
two they were doing it before that's we were just
saying happening already oh I totally didn't
capture you guys men yeah it's oh and he's
got the bones on his sweatshirt too that's
a great cuz that boy did design Choice yeah
how many times a week are you serious no
no no Kate she didn't make you do it did
she you wanted to I'm sorry I thought you
were my best friend whoa of my a so long
man yeah I don't know they have
powers in her mind go go go go
go damn so she feels guilty I hope so yeah and
he feels guilty it's good they could reuse all
these sets now getting their money out of all this
hey oh yeah I was going to say they separated him
do we think he's in there this isn't Cas mry he
fine emerging worlds yeah you can that's really
neat oh was a mind trip it's all right buddy it's
all right I'll tell you everything full of [__]
breathe deep breath oh everyone's everyone's got
some dark secrets oh no she's also been covering
up for everything she's a brilliant receptionist
she does so much love and Beyond I'd just really
and to be the one that who actually fought him
later on Luke needs cuttingedge treatments that
boy could be homelander strong sometimes he
has a bad reaction if L's getting Cutting
Edge treatments I want him too always looking up
for yourself huh shut up you were one to talk je
we were just there you weren't looking out for
yourself people just don't understand the lows
it takes to reach Great Heights so now I want you
to promise me as my new ta that you will always
protect me big job I'm honored good I guess
the lesson is we've all done terrible things
he said he was juicing Golden Boy what would any
of you done something Jordan we could have stopped
everything right here cool nice but instead we're
a TA saving our own ass I love drink he was good
or not but he was good to us he was nice I love
how this is also represent the duality of them
yeah for us to let someone get royally one's
breaking down and crying and one's angry and
standing up oh yeah real dichotomy on screen
yeah oh personified dichotomy yeah and lots of
duplicitousness oh quite that's also just a great
encapsulation of like so many conversations that
are culturally happening right now when people get
exposed in like positions of power and that's a
great Point complicity like and the fact that it
was her and him dialogued out the way it was it's
great that was amazing the time you went cookie
I don't think I can do that 247 I mean maybe
237 I'm messed up Emma you should be with
someone that isn't well maybe I want to
be with you I mean I'm messed up too me I
have really bad breath really bad and we
both smell like sweaty popcorn sweaty popcorn
what is sweaty popcorn hope it's a combination
of their smelling the popcorn in the room
not like popcorn sweaty popcorn is a guy in
this universe he's one of the most famous
Heroes with his butter Cannon what do you
see oh wow he's being Juiced off his brother oh
that's messed up that is wild oh oh and he's got
remember for a moment oh that's how oh wake
up Sam what this oh wow how torturous you're
going to forget this is happening oh my God
you're going to forget about the wood that is
your brother is dead oh she has been through
so much you kind of predicted some like that
in the first episode I did I don't love it I
don't love being right but the delivery is so
much harsher this is like New Mutants czy he
keeps remembering like like a damn breaking
you're helping him Kate you're doing a wonderful
job oh God they are so evil make them forget no
no no that she could see you in her own mind it's
a great representation of like everything falling
apart and madness madness like brainwashing
almost oh no I know that door oh it's time
to go in your mind the bathroom door you got
to get out yeah I think it is is the thing
she's protected herself from so long thinking
about like she has to go through it which is
acceptance soow we're going to find out she
Dick someone over yeah you killed them I didn't
mean to you were angry that they barged in and
and everything that happened happened because
you wanted it to what oh is that she feels no
matter how hard you try to be a hero always be
a murderer to me oh I'll never forgive you and
you shouldn't either oh you told me it wasn't
my fault who who's the benefactor minute crying
over them what happened to your brother was an
accident I know that you think it's your fault
I think talking to her yeah for when they had
oh I see you shouldn't be here Kate oh World
turned upside down you can wake up right now
I won't stop you anymore you're up I'm up you
got to forgive yourself too Kate yeah you're
manipulated me and I know your parents hurt
you that's shett I see it hurt people hurt
people but I wish you would have chose something
different because I love you and I don't want to
love you because I'll never trust you again you
finally have a choice so wake the up you don't
get to throw this all away you finally have
Choice my the line that does it so wake up
is this real yes oh oh thank God
you're here you found him you have sex
hair Jordan is Sam oh boy oh no oh he
knows no no no no he just went through this
oh yeah I was worried about that oh man
did she just come back to get killed oh
no oh no oh no oh no let her go she H
you and she H Luke you don't have to
hurt her back hey look at me trust
me right let her go indana let it
go damn what is Shetty doing down there I
don't know they were using Sam to augment
Luke's Powers Shetty was directing it all so
she's the answer we do this and there's no
going back we going back I didn't mean to I was
just following your orders yes she did P She a
pancake now what's going on D oh Jeeps man we
killed soup my God that's great she's so happy
they have the power to do kill soup yeah yeah
only 5 mm more that was all now can you make it
contagious of course of course chus man
Jesus that's going to affect the whole yeah
that's going into season four of the boys
now there's going to be like a which is a super
X-Men thing thing like having a virus that takes
away your powers or kills you or both uh is very
much I wonder if Garn is doesn't like this show I
know Dereck loves it I've heard the show is very
different Sensi sensibly from the books I feel
like Garis hates supers and I think here there a
superhero show and like I could see how I can like
the boys but I could where this would really
bother I'm like the the protagonists are the
supers in this yeah they're getting all the like
positive and they're actually getting the humans
are the bad ones and it's such a flip the humans
are totally bad where like the boys the humans I
mean there's some terrible humans but but the
humans and there yeah um but here it's like no
all the humans the parents suck the teachers suck
manipulator yeah who looking out for themselves
but we feel sorry for the supers and the supers
are going to be one who could help save the day
uh that was brilliant that was my favorite
episode of the season so far absolutely I
think that in episode one are my my two favorites
yeah this the one just surprised me out of nowhere
visually provocative um mindbending and all
accounts but not just for visual flare it was
doing it to really help serve a greater narrative
overall and a way to do some just solid visual
storytelling or diving deep into Kate Kate's going
into Kate's mind and understanding her backstory
more it does surprise me how good she is that
she's very socially capable that I I would feel
like she'd be a lot shy a lot of YouTube yeah
there's got to be a way she's like socialized
she she has to like yeah I mean probably just
learn via Media or maybe was trained but it's
just she seems so capable of social it's the
one psychological element of it that kind of
throws me off a tad bit is This Woman's been so
cage and then she goes to school and she seems
like she knows how to flirt she wants to fix so
bad I think it's just like how do I blend in how
do I fix myself how do I get people to like me
like her whole character is how do I get people
to like me and her trying to not feel like she's
doing the wrong thing while knowing she is yeah I
think it's I think the answer is there in the
show I don't I don't feel like it's a flaw or
criticism really it was the one thing that was
like huh interesting well and there's a pretty
solid gap of time between when Shetty comes
and takes her to when we join her now I mean
still like decently young at that point right
I mean nine plus she looked like n years how
long how old do you think she was when she her
brother did she say was like seven something 16
and college is like 19 I think yeah I think you
could partly imagine it as like you're thinking
back on yourself you probably imagine yourself a
little more articulately or whatever than you were
at a younger age oh that's a good point too like
her memory of herself was probably like you know
social she might be like feral but yeah maybe
through this experience going away with Shetty
that would easily open her up to you know at least
some sociality with other kids who probably she's
not a fresh Sim experience she's like a sophomore
or Junior so that's why I was saying I'm like
19 should have some time because the Monica is
the only freshman right yeah it's a Monica Mar
yeah it's a good thing her Towers went berserk
otherwise it wouldn't have been able to come to
a point of understanding yeah would never forgive
each other killed would not have suffice have to
Legion wipe everyone and then come together they
had to really go all into the memory Noggin there
and that is the only way it could really come to
a true sense of understanding is allowing them
to experience it vicariously tell me my friends
forgive each talking about yeah you just got to
go into the minds yeah those sound bath parties I
invite you to we just get in a room we just five
minut I know everyone's performance here is so
strong though and this is a a story of like like
a lot of superhero stories a lot of it is about
self-acceptance and everyone here has a journey
of self- forgiveness self-acceptance and really
zeroing in on everyone's flaws and what makes
them human is is the the Dual emotions of
everyone even right down to Marie I love I
love dealing with that core memory of hers of
seeing how yeah when she was really young she
even there was a part of her that wanted to use
her power and that part of her lives on through
her sister or like through the iconography of her
sister yeah yeah you know like I'm not saying she
like wanted to kill or deep down she's an evil
per that's not a baby snake thing like in that
moment you were enraged enough that you directed
this energy you didn't understand at them rather
than it just happening inexplicably yeah yeah
and I like acknowledging that that that's very
human to me even if that was only 1% of the moment
that character in her little sister represents the
1% of her that was just angry even if it was 99%
yeah I love that moment very strong stuff and uh
again great use of Schwarzenegger coming back
I thought that was so clever they've brought
him back like three different episodes and they
have all felt natural yeah he's like an actual
character Golden Boy Patrick when did he come back
before oh yeah had another flashback yeah yeah but
all the flashbacks haven't been like just to have
them like they saw flashbacks yeah they actually
we need them on screen like their narrative like
really functional he served a Creator ner in the
show than I ever would have expected considering
he died in the pilot yeah no he feels like he's
part of The Ensemble even though he is dead
and his presence looms throughout every episode
great yeah yeah the Jordan stuff with the the both
characters both actors that play Jordan getting to
actually act opposite each other is so fulfilling
because it fits narratively but it also shows how
well cast it also shows like how well Logan is is
acting as I don't know the other person's name but
how well London sorry not Logan how well London
is acting like uh their male M male counterpart
but then when you see them on screen together
like how they've worked on having each other's
little ticks and things but then when they're
facing each other like you were saying like the
guilt and anger versus like in that moment like
The Duality of their emotion in that section was
genius represented their physicality of when they
switch in and out so it kind of makes me want to
it weirdly makes me want to go back rewatch The
episodes and see the emotional intentional choices
of when um it's the male counterpart versus the
female counterpart I don't know if that's the
correct terminology I'm dealing with a a character
who could actually transgender character who could
actually switch in and out yeah all right the
male identifying counter yeah male presenting
male pres I don't know the the way to not offend
I'm sorry um so yeah but to see the to see that
would be really interesting because they were two
very different emotions in that moment right right
right I thought that was fascinating cuz like you
said everyone got their character Arc but theirs
was the visual representation of what everyone
was actually feeling which is the dichotomy of
the emotion they were going through I'm surprised
it wasn't rushed this epod like this normally
it's a short episode yeah this is the shortest
I think run time but the most stuff and it was
really thick and I think it's because you're just
diving straight on into something where you're not
relying you're you're dealing with a lot of things
that are going really in your face about it yeah
while simultaneously having just enough exposition
to deal with it that you're you have to face it so
head on as an audience member with the characters
that you surprised they don't feel like they're
rushing through arcs it manages to be thoughtful
without losing momentum and without losing tension
cuz like at one point I was afraid actually that
we weren't I think it was with Jordan they have
this start the conversation in the office about
like you know the whole complicity of of them you
know backing up Brink and why and then you know
that conversation continues sort of into the next
scene and then transitions into the next character
and uh and I don't know I just I thought that
was like kind of graceful Within this and it's an
episode where I didn't really notice the time and
then you can like I thought just to add to that
like the the Jordan's talk is also great because
so much of what this show deals with is cycles of
pain and and cycles of I don't know power dynamics
and oppression and stuff like that but also how
people can be complicit and lie to themselves
about why they do that stuff and also you know the
idea that you might know somebody who is you know
not who they seem to be and they're good to you
and they're you know a positive presence in your
life but meanwhile they're hurting other people
that's like such a close toome discussion that
so many things have bungled that I thought this
handled really nicely within that one character of
like look at where we are we're a TA we could have
actually like helped some people not be I mean you
know there's a greater system at play we probably
would have gotten taken down in the process but we
could have done the right thing in the face
of this instead of accepting all those lies
of oh he's like a father to me oh he's this he's
that and uh and yeah it's like in an episode like
this I'm surprised that they it's to the writing
and the directing and everyone's credit that it
feels as graceful as it does cuz that felt like
a really thoughtful and a great example of one of
these things that's in the style of such popular
media that's often trying to like throw you out a
woke idea or something like that but that's like
a super thoughtful moment within something that's
still moving and still sci-fi and it's still all
the other things that you want I agree and and
and to add to that I I think not only does it
do all of those things but the speed is able to
accomplish so much because each of their sections
not only Builds on the last one but they share so
much trauma that like say Jordan's like guilt
about the TA thing mirrors the guilt that Marie
feels mirrors the guilt so they can jump into
the next scene and ride the emotional wave of
whatever that emotion is like you're falling out
of one person suddenly spiking and guilt going
to the other person's guilt so it doesn't need
two scenes it needs one and a half into the next
person's half and the next person's half so the
pacing gets to be genius because we've all lived
for five episodes going to this sixth building
to this climax of you have to actually address
this thing that happened to you and then we know
the 78s of the setup then this one we got like all
of that in Rapid Fire through the emotional
connection which is genius what is the okay
what's the dean's name and what's Clancy Brown's
name Shetty and Brink shett is the dean Brink is
the what I think what I think the show has really
laced throughout this whole season in particular
so well is is the focus on the parents and how the
parents have been pretty abusive and they accepted
a deal that would monetize and take advantage
of their kids and yet they would also judge
and condemn them uh for not going down certain
paths they want like the parents are Terri like
are awful sure I mean I feel like I'm blanking on
maybe a good one good parent foot I kind but for
the most part they're they're all awful or dead
and then what they've done with Shetty and Brink
is they have made them both the surrogate father
and mother I totally agree when you mentioned
br's like paternal presence I think said it to
one point I'm like oh wow that's a really good
way to make it like hey you need me you haven't
had me exactly they they totally they like prey
on children who it's it's like it's such a weird
cycle of what VA does yeah of they uh persuade
these parents take advantage of the parents and
then they like they make sure the parents are like
terrible [__] people yeah and then they step
in and become the parents to the kids you this
episode was we haven't mentioned the best Cameo
I've seen a long time yeah it's about my mind I
was just about to think cuz all the stuff you're
saying I'm like all right and then the first typ
of the episode does all the stuff with VA but
personifies it in the most ridiculous like H
Rock Character and allows him to be an 11 allows
him to say all the stuff that clearly Jin nles has
been dying to say for years like the joy in that
performance but it personifies what VA has been
doing not only as the the you know boyfriend the
guy the the guy I'm dating in Canada element but
also what that represents in this show and what
super represent in this world it was cool that
he got to play the the image of soldier boy yeah
and not cuz we we we know what Soldier Boys really
like right he got to play like the caricature of
yeah but he still have the beard and everything
oh so good but like reded yeah yeah that was
really fun I fart Spangles like it was just
so many great I want to rewatch just that scene to
experience the dialogue again in real time because
it was masterfully delivered and ridiculous that
was so fun seemed like they let him riff oh that
definitely was like the kind of cutting that was
happening there it it works great cuz it's like
it could be an improv bit but because of the kind
of jarring cutting it works with the weird types
of way your mind moves at a rapid Pace I want the
seven minute cut of just Jens snackles going to
town cuz I guarantee it's out there's got to be
like I hope you know they always do the on a day
and then four days later Amazon's like okay let's
get the other half the people that didn't watch
and then they just release that please Amazon
release the Jens knackles cut yeah yeah um man
there's a lot of happen here because that oh no I
was going to say that was terrific but also uh uh
Emma and Sam like that whole subplot up together
was like the sweetest counter I thought that was a
really nicely placed Counterpoint cuz that could
have happened a lot of places the was great but
yeah it's like it's you have a me a crazy mental
intimacy happening on the one hand as we get to
our Chara it's like this is the character climaxes
episode before we take it to the streets so like
which is weird usually the penultimate yeah it's
usually episode seven this was six but the climax
had to come early cuz it's its first time sure
sure and I thought they made that really sweet
whilst also incorporating still you know the the
like you have that dread of like is this going to
become like a a bad trip and it does become a
sort of hallucination but it doesn't become a
bad trip and it does kind of read yeah like this
80s kind of awkward but super sweet and endearing
kind of moment yeah I like that it didn't ruin the
moment but it definitely made you like worried for
her it built it built tension and and it gave it
Stakes but like the sky sex didn't become like a
negative thing for him too long yeah and it's the
kind of thing that in this universe is usually so
lurid and so kind of used for shock and humor that
it was nice to see A Moment Like That treated with
tenderness and actual yeah just kind of like
character intimacy felt real did very very much
so yeah that was great that was beautiful and I
think this might be my favorite episode this is
a th% my favorite episode by by like there's not
even a competition honestly episode one was just
so unique in that it it balanced so many tone
but I think this one wins though cuz you're
right this is just it it accomplished so much in
like 30 something minutes um but I gotta say man
Andre seems like an awful person yeah he's the
only one I'm like he's actually the only his Arc
exactly he does not seem humbled by this situation
the second after the second after he gets caught
he's like way to not be accountable and I was
like you're boning dudes girl the second scene
and I liked his plea to her to wake up and I I
liked his admission of love but yeah of all the
character that had such kind of touching Journeys
and and very clearline Journeys well what I like
about him is he he seems like he he's the one who
propels them to want to do heroic acts like what
I still believed even though he was criticizing
uh Jordan in that moment I did believe him when
he said I would have done something and I know
and I feel like he would have done something and
it's a different kind of thing it's a different
kind of thing it's a completely different thing
and I still think that even though I still feel
like he would have tried to like do the right
thing in terms of oh this really cruel things
happening to Luke right yeah yeah yeah to Luke
um real real cruel things happening to Luke he
would have tried to do something as we've seen
in Prior episodes he will still try to do the
heroic path and uh yeah I think I'm playing
it the consequences of other actions later but
there still seems to be like there's yeah there
still seems to be this lack something that I've
been we've been talking about is like it seems
like there's this lack of guilt well there's a
lack of accountability everyone else has some
accountability for their actions every single
other character like good bad everything in the
middle human has an accountability and he's just
like you're all [__] up why I'm like dude you're
you're you're sleeping with her but when you he
was alive you contined to sleep with her it's
just Justified because you love her well and and
it's also I think very College I think it's maybe
it makes sense as to why it happens this way but
I think it is maybe the one episode aspect of the
episode that gets garbled by the fact that that
becomes a sort of action moment because he Flames
out and you know it becomes about you know not
being obliterated in fact does that one guy die
for real yeah so yeah like that guy got got smoked
got splattered so yeah it's like instead of having
him and Luke have like a scene type resolution
you know that was a representation of it we kind
of stone skip away from that I feel like yeah
I think we need I still feel like there needs
to be something more uh developed in that Arena
and then now they're controlling they have a way
to control the soups yeah they've got a weapon
yeah woof hell yeah imp it's coming it's got to
affect boy season 4 unless unless they just burn
this all down likee eight or something yeah no I
feel like I feel like didn't get out it's a new
Stakes element especially with homelander being
as powerful he is and the Way episode uh season
3 ended I mean because if from the trajectory of
homelander who has been playing so much by his
own rules uh it's like a big part of how vot has
been able to control soups has been them wanting
to be liked to put it in the most simplistic terms
you know especially homelander on the most like
Amplified level of of really caring what people
think about him and he just wants to be loved
and now he's been doing that by just doing his
own thing he even kills he even kills someone in
the middle broad daylight on everyone's like W
homelander uh just some random guy in a crowd but
he wants to be admired and like once he realizes
that's admiration it's like well that's what
I've been wanting to do and then you got these
Millennials yeah all these genz kids get yeah
genz who wants to do their own thing you want
to come up and be a real hero not a selfish
one and now they need to they need to find a
way to control the thing they created right and
this would be it and if they have a weapon that
could literally murder them yeah that changes the
stakes for the rest of the univers crazy I wonder
if our boys like get involved buter would want to
something like this oh he definitely would yeah
but he's also got compound V in his veins now so
does Jack or so does huie so we don't know who's
representing Marie though still yeah and I can't
put a theory on it it's her sister yeah there's no
I imagine it's a boy's Cameo but I can't think
of any boy that would be like a benefactor for
anyone everyone's too selfish in the boys like
the seven are all like who I feel like there's got
Starlight cuz she thinks that she can like help
from inside I don't know like it's such a stretch
yeah it's Starlight May how crazy it would be for
ma oh isn't she isn't she dead Ma's not dead wait
M's dead is ma dead did they fake her death or is
she actually dead oh I got to rewatch it cuz I was
I was going to say that then I had the thought
of like wait a minute though didn't did she die
or did she or or was it a kind of thing where
also I've got a medium issue where I'm like am
I remembering reading or watching yeah yeah yeah
I feel like it'd be laced throughout the season
season if she was dead maybe I'm thinking of print
print media Crimson count has definitely died she
did but uh she handed her last hand homelander
wouldn't do it uh no no no I mean Adrian wouldn't
really have a good reason to do it who who plays
Jim Jim Beaver what was his character he's like
a he's like a politician I don't know why he
would do it yeah would uh it'll be Jared pad
oh buter would he like want a soup in the inside
mother's milk is her uncle what uh what happened
with John car her name is m too she's an mm holy
[__] though she is an mm she's Marie Maro they
could be like distantly related what's his real
name I don't remember if that's really funny name
like Calvin or something but but if she wears
any sort of hip-hop t-shirt at one point we'll
know they're because of all of his great what
happened with John Carlo again he he he had the
he was in power and then homelander took over
we should rewatch season 3 something to do with
head exploding girl didn't he like Mentor her or
something yeah trained her and then she betrayed
him she and she and homelander were like both yeah
and he like was using her you know the chat right
now Message Board is like it's obviously this
like what was it but if he's out of vot maybe
he's a been he got money would would he yeah he
would I mean would he be trying to like Mentor
I mean like I'm not sure I think it's like an
inside job situation I don't think it's mentoring
I think it's like someone wants someone in the
seven that's under their thumb I think someone
that's why I feel like wouldn't wouldn't what was
John Carlos character's name again uh uh edar Stan
Edgar yeah what would would he maybe he would
try to use her to go back in maybe but that's
why I was thinking like cuz I'm trying to think
not just character but also motivation sure well
and what would it be about her in particular what
what is it about her power that moment she could
take out homelander probably yeah I mean she's got
power well especially if she can like percolate
his blood and stuff like that yeah that's fair
that is like a it is a uniquely we see it used
to make like blades and things a lot but I feel
like they've made a really cool point over the
season continuing that she can do yeah these other
things internally also they should animate Carnage
like that it's so cool and gross yeah but you know
yeah she can heal but she can also like Rend you
from the inside out so I mean yeah she would be a
pretty powerful seven number yeah I think butcher
is a possibility just because the leverage within
the seven I think that uh Stanley Edgar is a great
idea I want it feels like a big but is Butcher
literally going to show up in episode 8 like
hey I need more people on my team like you know
I you had potential she's on the seven and then
he's like how do you think you got here like CU I
think she fully becomes a member of the seven and
then your boy Jack qu seems to hang out with these
guys it's true uh oh is he coming and is he gonna
be Nick Fury got no suddenly got like I'm help you
to God you H's out there selling compound V on the
streets every time they say God you too it just
makes so good it's such a great douchy name for
people that are trying to be God douche name all
righty guys well it's a good one it was a good one
that was a great episode that's my favorite one so
far easily so good ex thank God for that Soldier
Boy Cameo one might get views that's what I'm
talking about we appreciate you internet for only
caring my not for the great episode not for great
writing or any boy we got halfway through our
commentary and I was like we hav mentioned so boy
the internet we'll want that yeah that's for guys
uh leave your thoughts down below leave a like on
this video that'd be very much appreciated what's
your favorite MCU C leave it below get yourself in
America's ass tape and hey let's send this with a
patron of the day shout out all right guys we got
to do some Patron catch UPS here and going within
the theme we're going to use our friends over at
chat gbt to help us get to know what people might
be like when our patrons interact with each
other now we're down to our last few we are
and here's the problem with the last few yes we
don't know them personally that well no normally
we have some facts about them and then we throw
it in there but now we're just going to have to
take a guess on what they're like to judge people
based on their name have to assume some of their
personality traits just off of the little bits of
interactions that we've had with them definitely
all right so let's get this show on the road so I
have a YouTube channel I'm prompting chat to you
to I'm going to shout out our patrons are super
sexy rejects uh which pair should we go with John
oh let's do Brian Perry and pandemic Jones oh my
God what's pandemic Jones's real name Paul Brian
Perry and P and Paul Jones yes all right all right
I want you to write a scene only do the dialogue
of them of them um escaping from Leatherface
in oh yeah oh no it's we'll put this in the saw
video escap jigsaw escaping from jigsaw create
a they are trapped together create a trap that
they have to survive together to get out of yeah
and what must they learn throw jigsaw in there at
the beginning yeah jigsaw tape the beginning a
jigsaw a jigsaw saw tape some facts about Brian
Perry and Paul Jones all right Paul likes to be
called pandemic Jones likes to be called pandemic
Jones that's true it's awarded nickname uh he's
a very upbeat and uh good-spirited person upbeat
and good-spirited person okay but but why would
he need to be taught a lesson from jigsaw cuz
he wants to cause a pandemic cuz he's too online
he's always online he wants to cause a pandemic
he wants to cause a pandemic that's even better um
we yeah always online never living too much in his
in the real world in the real world yeah in the
moment um he he has has has stolen fruit from the
grocery store oh no and uh let's see how old do
you think he is uh he's like 23 23 years old yeah
male um very buff very buff but with glute impacts
uh glute uh implants and lies to people that he
did it all natural oh no oh my God okay now Brian
Perry I really don't know much about this guy we
shout him out all the time so we's going to take I
guess um okay he's a cop I think in real life he's
a cop it's a s I believe Brian is probably our
oldest Patron he is 98 years old he is he's old on
90 years old and he's been scamming his Medicare
been scamming his Medicare has had has had three
to four wives yes um who have all mysteriously
disappeared disappeared um oh he's uh obsessed
with Mel Gibson yeah yeah he's a he loves qanon
loves Q how do you spell q and on that's how woke
I am space a n o n loves q and on just the letter
Q uh uh ooh he's uh he he he makes inappropriate
comments to people online inappropriate comments
to people online uh and but overall a nice guy all
right make sure to create the Trap let's do this
let's see how creative you can be let's see if
they can write the next saw installment let's do
this saw XI saw levam all right take it away John
interior dimly lit room night Paul pandemic Jones
and uh Brian Perry find themselves in a dimly lit
grim room their eyes adjust to the darkness as
they both realize they are chained to opposite
walls a large electrical panel with tangled wires
between them above the panel a monitor flickers on
revealing the Eerie puppet face of jig saw hello
Paul and Brian let's play a game Paul your online
Persona has consumed you making you miss out on
the genuine experiences of life and Brian despite
your service you've made choices that conflict
with your role as a protector of society uh to
escape this room you must literally reconnect with
each other no the screen shows a demonstration
there are 10 wires five from Paul's side and five
from Brian's they must match the right wire to
each side to form five correct pairs a wrong match
sends an electrical shock it's like this video
game this is so light uh Paul your thefts from
The Real World represented by the fruits of your
labor will guide Brian and Brian your knowledge of
True Crime will help Paul but hurry you have five
minutes before the room becomes your final resting
place the screen goes dark all right I'll be Brian
all right trying to maintain some composure all
right pandemic let's put aside our differences
and we're together I faced tougher situations in
many years all right Oldtimer I must be all oh
let's do it again all right then I don't know all
right pic let's our differences we M together I
face tougher situations in my years all right Old
Timer I might be all about the Dig digal world but
right now we're very much in the real one let's
do this I us to see symbols in my end a melon
an apple a banana reminds me of Mel Gibson movie
when you was a thief I can't recall the name of
that movie but I think it happened once this is
a real trap is to figure out what that movie is
uh those are the fruits I stole match the melon
with the green wire on your side what symbols
Do you have a bloody C badge a wedding ring a
Medicare card a q symbol and an online comment
section okay connect the badge with the blue
wire we've got this minutes feel like hours as
they continue connecting wires getting uh minor
shocks along the way but ultimately finding the
right connections you know for someone assists
with online stuff you're not half bad in person
and for a cop with such a twisted past you're
not the worst partner in a tight spot with the
final wire connected the chains release freeing
them we did it kid we sure did old man that's
it they that's all you could created escaped the
deadly tra Nails learn they learned the value of
genuine connection what a great setup you totally
canned everything about I know you didn't include
Jolan I'm going to I'm going to criticize
GB notes rewrites yeah oh my God you didn't
include Jack about Paul's back background
that we gave you it was so light it was so
light apologies over sight all right we're
going to redo this all right we got the Trap
pass Secrets oh no there's a whole different
track oh my God it's totally redoing the scene
oh it's redo doing everything Paul pandemic
Jones and Brian Perry trapped in a room Bound
by chains between them are a series weights
and pulley attached to Paul's side as a heavy
weight marked virtual world on Bryant's side
there's an even heavier weight labeled past
Secrets above them a tape recorder dangles Paul
manages to nudge it and it begins to play I yeah
sure
sayic jigaw here s you've been lost in the virtual
world so consumed by your digital life that
reality eludes you Brian your past is heavy with
Secrets weighing you down and preventing you from
moving forward today you must face those burdens
together to escape ball you must physically lift
your weight symbolizing your online obsessions
Brian to help him reveal the secret of every
Milestone Paul achieves making your weight lighter
and easier to lift if neither of you is honest or
committed neither of you gets out remember
sometimes the heaviest burdens we carry are
the ones we hide the tape clicks off that's good
all right there's like two lines of dialogue let's
see what the hell they do okay struggling to lift
okay I'll admit it these glutes not all natural I
got implants but I tell everyone I got them from
squats confession time okay wife number two it
wasn't a mysterious disappearance she left me for
a Mel Gibson impersonator they continue in this
vein each Revelation lightening the weights bit by
bit I I might want to cause a pandemic online but
I'm terrified of real life confrontations and
I've never actually confronted my feelings for
well real people I've scanned Medicare oh true
not because I needed the money but because I
felt invisible in my old age I just wanted to feel
seen F finally finally after much effort and the
Revelation the chains release you know for an old
cop you've got quite the story and you kid might
want to spend a bit more time in the real world
it's not all that bad this was a better version
Chad GPT I like that Chad GPT came up with traps
at least these are jigsaw esque traps all right
in like 10 seconds it's not too bad that's
your shout out guys we tried it we we did
it